Wow she's already got a little bit of
facial hair as well wonderful
cue the Royal horns it's time to meet
baby Sussex magic it's pretty amazing
and I have the two best guys in the
world so I'm really
on Wednesday Megan Markel and Prince
Harry introduced their newborn son to
the world
archie Harrison mountbatten-windsor what
a name because the sweetest temperament
is really
[Music]
it's been a special couple days the
Dutchess of Sussex looked amazing in a
white knee-length sleeveless dress by
london-based designer grace Wales Bonner
paired with Manolo Blahnik heels okay
this is not real life I'm pretty sure
two days after I have a baby I'm gonna
be waddling around in sweatpants and an
adult diaper anywho Harry looked up her
in a gray suit and a dark tie as he held
their itty-bitty teeny tiny little one
so who does maybe Archie look like
everyone says the baby's changed so much
over two weeks we've basically
monitoring Hartley
this next month really changed his looks
are changing every single day the couple
also opened up about their first few
days of parenting it's great parenting
is amazing it's pretend to be locked in
our page three days but we're just we're
just so thrilled to have our own little
bundle of joy spending precious times
with them as a state slowly starts to
grow
next up Megan and Harry introduced the
babe to the fam including the queen
Kensington Palace shared this pic of the
moment baby Archie met her Royal
Highness and we just bumped into the
Jupiter walking by which was so nice so
nice
introduce the baby to have more
No another great round rose that's right
another great grand baby baby Sussex who
was born on Monday morning weighing 7
pounds 3 ounces joins his cousins Kate
Middleton and Prince William's children
Prince George Princess Charlotte and
Prince Louis and the kindness just means
so much
we don't know who the godparents are
just yet but get this royal experts are
saying that the Clooney's and Oprah are
in the running the Clooney's and Oprah
hell yeah also people are calling
attention to the fact that Prince Harry
was the one who was carrying his son
historically it's the mom who comes out
holding the newborn you might remember
Kate held all three of her babies when
introducing them outside of the hospital
so what was that about
of course we'll be here to answer all
those burning questions so be sure to
keep it locked on ET until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]